this is a road
that few ugandans wish to follow
a gravel track which leads to the home
of opposition leader
bobby wine his house has been
cut off by troops and riot police and
members of mr wine's team
have been stopped and beaten there's no
such thing as protective custody
but a pair of lawyers who pulled up
before the police barricade
told us they were determined to get
through
we know that his home is not a detection
center and we know that
it's a private property so we're going
to try to see how we can access it
the lawyers edged slowly towards the
roadside blockade
designed to muzzle the popular
politician they argue
after a contentious campaign although
the police say mr wines being protected
for his own safety
and one of them is access to his lawyers
especially now that he's under detention
we need to take instructions from him
and this is standard the commander made
a phone call
then said no one's getting in how can
you say that
the lawyers were baffled and frustrated
when they left
just wondering what you make of it oh
this is futile we cannot access him
even people in police cells are
accessible
an impromptu press conference was
convened under the watchful eyes of the
security services
they're just here like money queens they
can't talk to you
they can't say a thing which is very
disturbing but our lawyers will let you
know
and how we are going to proceed on these
matters the lawyers are still having
their
press conference over there and a
company of troops
have appeared from a thicket of trees
and walked directly past us and
i have to say the atmosphere is is
really intimidating
bobby wine was contacted by phone and
said the situation
inside the cordon was desperate we had
one
shot of food supplies
but when my wife tried to go to our
garden
to take food she was assaulted by the
military the
only practical plan now is to inform the
wives
to see that our fellow citizens of the
world can help us
the authorities have done this before
five years ago
the then opposition leader was detained
for 40 days
after an election but there is less
tolerance at home
and abroad for dictatorial practices
like these john sparks sky news kampala